en soldat russe mort pour la plupart
face contre terre et semble-t-il touché
par balle à la tête cette vidéo est la
preuve selon Moscou de crimes de guerre
commis par les Ukrainiens ces militaires
auraient été abattus alors qu'il
venaient de se rendre voici l'extrait
d'un reportage russe diffusé vendredi
pas de parents les bras levés sans arme
on voit très bien que les prisonniers ne
représentent aucun danger et après après
ils sont fusillés que s'est-il
réellement passé ces soldats russes sont
morts dans l'est de l'Ukraine la région
de luansk est plus précisément dans une
ferme à maquille IFCA village reconquis
par Kiev ces dernières semaines un con
ukrainien a publié le 12 novembre une
série de vidéos de l'opération comme
souvent une musique accompagne le
montage
les Ukrainiens progressent dans la ferme
et voici les Russes qui se rendent
allez-y un par un main en évidence
allongé au sol la situation semble sous
contrôle
jusqu'à la sortie du dernier soldat
russe
[Musique]
image s'arrêtent alors on ralentissant
la vidéo on voit que le dernier soldat
russe ne s'est pas rendu il est armé et
ouvre le feu ce que confirme les Russes
dans la vidéo suivante les soldats sont
morts mais impossible de savoir dans
quelles circonstances
l'Ukraine a-t-elle alors commis un crime
de guerre contre des prisonniers selon
certains spécialistes ce qui s'apparente
à des exécutions pourraient être
considéré comme une scène de combat car
tous les Russes n'avaient pas déposé les
armes le fait qu'il y a un tiers de
riposte et donc des membres des forces
armées russes encore armées qui sont
encore en mesure de mener des combats
peut effectivement
expliquer cette scène et le fait qu'il
ne s'agit pas d'un crime de guerre mais
bien d'une opération militaire qui est
faite l'Ukraine rejette les accusations
de Moscou et annoncent une enquête comme
l'ONU qui promet d'examiner les vidéos